oh
holy [ __ ]
welcome back
i just saw the shadow for the first time
when it [ __ ] creeped me out it
i have no idea what am i supposed to do
i seriously seriously seriously don't
want to run into him
oh god
let's take it easy
we can do this he was in that room and
he walked over there
there's got to be another way around
this
you can do this
you're a man come on
it's just a [ __ ] game
just a [ __ ] game
let's try and think where i came from so
i can just rush through that [ __ ]
corridor because this is giving me the
[ __ ] creeps
[Music]
oh [ __ ] he's back
he's gotta be in there
where did i come from i want to get out
of here it was here wait was it here
please say it was oh my god oh my
[ __ ] god
the desert dance were like waves in
sluggish sea while the caravan moved the
land disappeared motionless button camp
the hills move
oh god
oh
that's
[ __ ] you
ouch
just a man
all right
i oh okay i need a break seriously
i'm gonna end this i'm gonna take a
break but i'm it's gonna end episode
this is too much for me right now sorry
all right i'm back i've been on a break
uh
seriously that was too much for me for a
while when i saw that monster i i just
wasn't ready for it
so
yeah and we're gonna move down to the
wine cellar
if my memory is
not
wrong then it's down
either here to the left or right i mean
or to the no that's the laboratory i
think this is the wine cellar
yeah
i need a key to unlock it so
um let's see here inventory there we go
oh that's how you do it
all right so let's head in here a
handful of sand tricked trickle it from
the crumbling stone ceiling and they
pushed down
uh on the brim of his hat he braced
himself as a cave and suddenly shifted
and settled
okay so i guess that's from my previous
experience in africa
okay
hear footsteps and
it creeps me the hell out
i've actually watched someone else play
this part
very little of it i remember hardly
anything and
i got it
or at least until tomorrow
[Music]
and i know i know you can't encounter
the [ __ ] monster here and ah
i don't want to see that thing again
it was so scary
uh my guess is that
what just happened when enemies near
yeah okay someone's surely about to come
now
[ __ ]
holy jeez
okay let's check in here
[ __ ] [ __ ]
oh he's oh he's oh he's up there
hey
it's it's like from a living nightmare
this game seriously
literally this game
oh we gotta
ha ha no no camp in the corner camp in
the corner
[Music]
why is this game so [ __ ] scary
ah
[ __ ]
seriously
[Laughter]
it's just a [ __ ] game let's do this
okay
it's not it can't harm you i'm camping
in the corners
it's fine it's fine you can't see me
i got this
[ __ ]
please go away
god damn it
i i don't want to go there i really
really really don't want to go there i
want to sit in my [ __ ] corner and cab
holy [ __ ] jesus
is he upstairs again
i don't want to use my
this lantern
this [ __ ] game
holy [ __ ]
i got head pounding hands are shaking
that's for [ __ ] sure
let's see what's here
because you guys probably can't see
anything if i
if i don't have the landlord
all right
and i might have all
well i got three that's not very much
i should use it more carefully
let's see
i would not be surprised if i saw him
again here
oh
good
need as many of those as i have
oh
oh no
no
there's got to be a way to hide
[ __ ]
[ __ ] mice
god damn it all right in the box
need that for later
stay in the light
can't stay in the darkness for too long
all right
oh
who's saying that
[ __ ]
oh great i need that
wait wait wait wait
it's so hard to hear i keep hearing
footsteps
what am i supposed to do down here i
just want to get the [ __ ] out
all right i guess we gotta go in here
close the door
there's no way to light
all right
oh geez oh geez he's close
i bet i wonder if i can open doors
let's see if i can see him out
no
all right
i bet there's something here no tools
let's see if there's something in behind
here
because i need as many
oils as i can get
wow these wine balls are really heavy
barrels that's what it's called
let's see here
oh there's got to be something there we
go
no
there's gotta be something in here
because i don't know what to do
otherwise
that creeps me out
i don't wanna waste this [ __ ]
let's check notes
that was that was the only hint to go to
the wine cellar
[ __ ] i'm screwed
let's see if it's out there